[Music]
hello there November is upon us once
again and the Christmas rush officially
begins as even more games VY for your
attention this is the series in which we
go through the best offerings of the
month from the AAA juggernauts to the
reduced price Beauties and a bunch of
free games to try out too and of course
some dad jokes to end let's do
this 35 years in the making comes
RoboCop Rogue City a firstperson shooter
based on the iconic 80s movie movies
with a branching storyline set after the
events of RoboCop 2 the game begins with
an assault on Channel 9 News who have
been taken over by a band of Outlaws
known as the torch heads RoboCop pulls
up voiced by his OG actor Peter Weller
and all hell breaks loose the thing
about Murphy here is that he's more than
a man he's heavily armored and augmented
with 1980s future technology and is
effectively a walking tank we'll be
using the police HQ to acquire more
missions and those won't all be about
shooting first and asking questions
later RoboCop will need to use
investigative skills first and then
resort to his Firearms seriously though
we can use dialog trees to get through
missions peacefully and we're told our
decisions have consequences the XP we
earn in game is funneled into upgrades
such as armor or on the other hand
psychological skills depending on your
preferred play style RoboCop Rogue City
drops on November 2nd on PlayStation 5
Xbox series and
PC
next up is Call Of Duty Modern Warfare 3
it's 2011 all over again this version of
Modern Warfare 3 is the final part of
the retelling of the original trilogy as
Captain Bryce and his task force look to
take down notorious bad guy macarov in a
cinematic campaign unrivaled by its
first-person shoot appears aside from
that it is confirmed a Zombies mode is
here once again which also has a
storyline to follow after a zombie
outbreak over 40 years earlier during
the Black Ops cold warrior events Call
of Duty gameplay is as tight as ever
with the same gameplay Loop we've been
addicted to for decades now with more
places to do it the campaign war zone
DMZ zombies and standard multiplayer 2
Modern Warfare is going to be huge on
both current and last gen on PS4 PS5 all
the Xboxes and PC on November
10th over the years there have been
numerous Yakuza games and spin-offs the
Yakuza name itself was officially
dropped last year and now like a dragon
is the c title which brings us to like a
dragon giden the man who erased his name
this action adventure game takes place
after the events of Yakuza 6 and Caesars
once again control Kazuma KIU who is now
in hiding as an underworld War breaks
out in essence the man who erased his
name is a brawler with two key fighting
styles to master Yakuza style which is
the bread and butter beat him up style
from previous games and now a new agent
style which is here to let kiau use
James bondes gadgets to to dominate the
battlefield as the story unfolds we run
around many open world districts with
many side quests and a crazy amount of
mini games to play from karaoke to toy
car racing and a massive back catalog of
classic Sega games is here to play in
your free time like a dragon giden the
man who erased his name has a
ridiculously long title and has the
potential to take over your life if you
let it November 9th on PlayStation 4 and
5 the Xboxes and
PC the Never ending presence of Persona
5 is here once again this time with the
Tactical version of events in this story
which runs concurrent with the standard
Persona 5 story The Phantom thieves are
transported into a new realm and must
stop an evil tyrant in power as we
understand this new world we'll fight
many legionnaires leading to an
interesting combat system a grid is
placed on the ground and just like XCOM
and other tactical based games we take
it in turns to move around the board and
attack with different spots offering
different cover and different attacking
options there's a pretty cool mechanic
when all enemies are surrounded by your
unit and a special team move is
available obliterating everyone in its
path the Laura Persona 5 continues to
grow so don't be fooled by this playful
art style there's a lot going on in this
universe Persona 5 tactica drops on
November 17th on the PlayStations the
Xboxes the PC and the perfect place for
it the
switch okie dokie let's look at some
free games that are coming in November
and a sneak peek at one of the ps+ games
this is Phantom Blade executioners a
free-play dark fantasy sidescrolling RPG
I know that sounds absolutely insane but
I reckon it's worth looking at We join a
mysterious order to investigate a spree
of unal livings in the world and Wade
through countless enemies to achieve
peace we select one of four Heroes each
with different abilities and weapons
like a ranged guitarist wielding
powerful Audio Waves while another is
all about unpredictable movement and an
elegant song I'm not sure how much skill
will be needed to play this or if it's
more of a brawler as not a great deal of
information is available right now on
November 2nd we can try Phantom Blade
executioners for ourselves on
PlayStation 4 and 5 PC and
mobile next a free sports game this is
metaball I showed you this a few months
back and now after a successful beta
metaball is fully released and out right
now the premise is simple score more
baskets than the other team the thing is
you're on a h board with a magnetic
Gauntlet to control the ball judging by
my research the hope is to turn metaball
into an esport with a similar control
and camera system as Rocket League
pushing players for more speed and
precision to stay on top with a bunch of
cosmetic items to unlock time will
ultimately be the judge of metaball will
you support it or avoid it one more free
game this month and it's already out
take a look at side bullet a Last Man
Standing Battle Royale with a Twist at
the start of each game we swing into a
tower block which is made made up of
many rooms over time they become toxic
forcing players closer together like a
typical storm Circle in a typical BR
game this is another Sid scroller more
like a twin stick shooter right 40
players jump into each game and
alongside that are a Litany of AI
zombies trying to take advantage when
your back is turned this adds an ambush
strategy to proceedings to get the upper
hand when another player is fighting AI
I've played for about a week now and I
have to admit the optimization on
PlayStation 5 is pretty bad and the low
time are horrible but the idea here is
pretty good anyway try it for yourself
on your PS5 right
now check this out the console version
of tear down drops on PlayStation and
Xbox on November 15th and will be
released straight into the ps+ extra
catalog how can I describe tear down H
if Minecraft made a heist game Tear Down
is essentially a destructible sandbox we
are given a mission to steal a certain
object and then let loose to decide our
own way of getting things done we need
to get in and out in a certain time or
risk being caught red-handed which makes
for some frantic Smash and grab
scenarios tear down has already received
a couple of DLC updates with more
support planned for 2024 i' like the
look of this game so I'm extremely happy
it's on ps+ on day one I look forward to
seeing all the dumb ways the community
gets things done November 15th on
PlayStation 5 Xbox series and it's
already out right now on
PC
one more game before we go a super cheap
one at that retailing at $30 €30 or £25
here in the UK take a look see at the
Talos principal 2 the first game was
well regarded as a single player puzzle
Masterpiece the tals principal 2 looks
to build on those Shaw foundations with
a narrative that guides us through the
puzzles and brain teasers as we discover
why biological humans are no longer in
this world we play as a robot and who is
testing these robots if you're down for
some thought-provoking puzzling grab the
Talos principal 2 on November 2nd there
are another 23 games releasing this
month but I think we'll stop there and
on top of that there is new hardware a
new Slimmer version of the PS5 is coming
soon as to is the PlayStation portal to
play your PS5 when you can't be with
your PS5 I plan to review that and let
you know if it's worth your money this
Christmas okay I owe you some dad jokes
for your time let's start small why did
the duck cover its bottom so you can't
see its butt quack no okay too immature
for you let me try again what's the
scariest plant in the forest
bamboo bamboo
Bamboo yeah you get it I'm Adam you're
awesome please leave me a dad joke in
the comments see
you